[Musique]
le titre s'appelle moulères engage
camerounais parce que là-bas mais mon
rôle des différentes langues j'ai vécu
cinq ans on n'y passe pas ça en fait
c'est un message à l'invitation
changement à venir découvrir l'afrique
[Musique]
j'aimais beaucoup ce qu'ils faisaient
ibrahim il a commencé dans le rap
ensuite ils évoluent est double non
l'unique brio il est plus prompte heures
slameurs et et l'hommage coller avec le
avec moi tout de suite c'est le
réalisateur canadien on a échangé
sincèrement ça c'est fait je pense en
deux semaines sur les idées global
le studio s'est elle frise celle à
l'extérieur tel prix d'ici donc ça
facilite aussi la chose et ensuite en
raison de la tournée en 24 heures on a
commencé en 5 milliards à 8 heures du
matin il a terminé le soir on s'était
mis juste à côté d'une pente d'un champ
domicile fixe et qui pendant tout le
tournage en fait qu'on bercy on était au
milieu il ya beaucoup de vélo qui passe
au pied de couper pas mal de fois
homogène et cette personne là il sortit
de sa pente et à et a fait en fait
l'orientation des cyclistes et leurs
visas non stop tournage à la droite à la
gauche en fait il nous a aidés pendant
tout le tournage et j'ai trouvé ça très
touchant